let's see if we can calculate the
definite integral from 0 to 1 of x
squared times 2 times 2 to the X to the
third power DX and like always I
encourage you to pause this video and
see if you can figure this out figure
this out on your own so I'm assuming
you've had a go at it and so there's a
couple of interesting things here the
first thing at least that my brain does
it says well I'm used to taking
derivatives and anti derivatives of e to
the X not some other base to the X so we
know that the derivative with respect to
X of e to the X is e to the X or we
could say that the antiderivative of e
to the X is equal to e to the X plus C
so since I'm dealing with a something
raised to a this particular situation
something raised to a function of X it
seems like I might want to put something
I might want to change the base here but
how do I do that well the way I would do
that is reexpress to in terms of e so
what would be to in terms of e well 2 is
equal to e is equal to e raised to the
power that you need to raise e to to get
to 2 well what's the power that you have
to raise e to to get to do well that's
the natural log of 2 once again the
natural log of 2 is the exponent that
you have to raise e to to get to 2 so if
you actually raise e to it you're going
to get 2 so this is what 2 is now what
is 2 to the X to the third well if we
raise both sides of this to the X to the
3rd power if we raise both sides to the
X to the 3rd power 2 to the X to the
third is equal to if I raise something
to an exponent and then raise that to an
exponent it's going to be equal to e to
the X to the 3rd X to the 3rd times the
natural log of 2 times the natural log
of 2 so that already seems pretty
interesting so let's let's rewrite this
and actually what I'm going to do is
let's just focus on the indefinite
integral first see if we could figure
that out then we can apply and then we
could take we can evaluate the definite
ones so let's just let's just think
about this let's think about the
indefinite integral
of x squared times two to the X to the
third power DX so I really want to find
the antiderivative of this well this is
going to be the exact same thing as the
integral of so I'll write my x squared
still instead of two to the X to the
third I'm going to write all of this
business let me just copy and paste that
we already established this is the same
thing as two to the X to the third power
copy and paste and just like that and
then let me just close it with a DX so I
was able to get it in terms of e as a
base that makes me a little bit more
comfortable but it still seems pretty
complicated but you might be saying well
okay look maybe u substitution could be
at play here because I have this this
kind of crazy expression X to the third
time's the natural log of two but what's
the derivative of that well that's going
to be 3x squared times the natural log
of two or three times the natural log of
2 times x squared well that's just a
constant times x squared we already have
an x squared here and so maybe we can
engineer this a little bit to have the
constant there as well so let's think
about that so if we made this if we
defined this as u so if we said u is
equal to X to the third times the
natural log of two what is d u going to
be well D U is going to be it's going to
be well natural log of 2 is just a
constant so it's going to be 3x squared
times the natural log of 2 and we can
actually just change the order we're
multiplying a little bit we could say
that this is the same thing as x squared
times 3 natural log of 2 which is the
same thing just using logarithm
properties as x squared times the
natural log of 2 to the 3rd power 3
natural log of 2 is the same thing as
the natural log of 2 to the 3rd power so
this is equal to x squared times the
natural log of 8 so let's see if this is
U where is D u oh and of course we can't
we can't forget the DX this is a DX
right over here DX DX
DX so where is the D you well we have a
DX let me circle things so you have a DX
here you have a DX there you have an x
squared here you have an x squared here
so really all we need is all we need
here is the natural log of eight so if
we ideally we would have a natural log
of eight right over here and we could
put it there as long as we also we can
multiply by a natural log of eight as
long as we also divide by a natural log
of eight and so we could we could do it
like heat right over here we could write
it divided by natural log of eight but
we know that the antiderivative of some
constant times a function is the same
thing as a constant times the
antiderivative of that function so we
could just take that on the outside so
it's one over the natural log of eight
so let's write this in terms of U and D
U this simplifies to 1 over the natural
log of eight times the antiderivative of
e e to the U e to the u that's the u D u
this times this times that is d u D U
and this is straightforward we know what
this is going to be this is going to be
equal to so let me just write the 1 over
natural log of 8 out here 1 over natural
log of 8 x times e to the U times e to
the U e to the U and of course if we're
thinking in terms of just antiderivative
there would be some constant out there
and then we would just reverse the
substitution we already know what u is
so this is going to be equal to the
antiderivative of this expression is 1
over the natural log of 8 times e to the
instead of U we know that U is X to the
3rd times the natural log of 2 and of
course we could put a plus C there now
going back to the original problem we
just need to evaluate the antiderivative
of this at each of these points so let's
rewrite this so given what we just
figured out so let me copy and paste
that this is just going to be
equal to it's going to be equal to the
antiderivative evaluated at one minus
the antiderivative evaluated zero we
don't have to worry about the constants
because those will cancel out and so we
are going to get we are going to get one
let me evaluate it first at one so
you're going to get 1 over the natural
log of 8 times e to the 1 to the third
power which is just 1 times the natural
log of 2 natural log of 2 that's it
evaluated at 1 and then we're going to
have minus it evaluated at 0 so it's
going to be 1 over the natural log of 8
times e to the well when x is 0 this
whole thing is going to be 0 well e to
the 0 is just 1 and e to the natural log
of 2 well that's just going to be 2 we
already established that early on this
is just going to be equal to 2 so we are
left with 2 over the natural log of 8
minus 1 over the natural log of 8 which
is just going to be equal to 1 over the
natural log of 8 and we are and we are
done